logic versus emotion is a false debate
because you can be very logical and
still be emotional and in fact we need
our emotions to problem solve creatively
so that's a false dichotomy between
emotional and rational so we can be very
rational and still be emotional it's
very important that we listen to the
emotional part of what our partners
perceptions are and how they make our
partner feel because if we don't listen
to the emotions then they won't feel
understood they won't feel respected we
have to develop that confidence to
really see and perceive emotions and if
we ignore emotions the repair we try to
make during conflict is not going to
work if it's all very cognitive and
intellectual and we're not really taking
into account our feelings and our
partners feelings we won't solve the
problem